[Musica]
sì barbara ci troviamo proprio qui nel
bagno di marina qui alla mia destra
potete vedere la sua doccia dove ha da
poco girato il video sulle tipologie di
ragazze in doccia
qua invece troviamo una sua realta e
pensate un po l'acqua micellare con la
quale si strucca tutte le sere per
adesso è tutto vada ti restituisco la
vigna ci sentiamo dopo per gli ultimi
aggiornamenti a te la linea ciao
mariners come avrete intuito insomma la
giornalista di poco fa vi ha già
anticipato che siamo proprio qui nel mio
bagno a grande richiesta la mia prima
make up collection
queste sono tutti nei prodotti in vetro
che la mia vita
se vi state chiedendo perché non ci sono
prodotti e di saldo
e perchè è giusto così perché ci sono
quattro scaffali ed è giusto che 4
scappare siano solo per me salvo ambiti
che il grosso così
e gli battete bene diciamo partiamo
subito dal primo scaffale innanzitutto
una zona ombretti questi sono tutti
ombretti le mie palais fantastiche di
nei che questi di sephora queste in aula
delle ciglia finte che non uso da quando
le ho comprate mi piacerebbe tanto
provarle ma non ho ancora avuto voglia
passiamo qua nella zona con touring
illuminanti blush ombretti questi sono
gli ombretti e e fard cipria di tutto un
po ecco è questa invece salerno che
secondo scaffale la zona proprio
propriamente più più foundation più
tinte labbra più soldi che fanno come
sempre
nessun domani partendo proprio da re
foundation questa mia rete spesso quale
fondo tito uso questo quadro baldi che i
bianchissimo perché ovviamente misys
carità la pelle quindi sono più bianca
del solito
e anche per quanto riguarda i correttori
mischio mixò questi due sempre di urban
decay che sono i più chiari sono casper
il mio cugino gay e queste sono le
labbra che avete già visto in qualche
video se non erro in vita sulle tinte
labbra chiaramente è però nel video
dell'intera però non avete visto tutti
rossetti dovrei fare un video dove trovo
tutti e rossetti
questi sono tutti l'imac poi ci sono
certe questo partito che è buonissima e
questi qua di cell phone poi c'è questo
olio di chi sa che metto prima insomma
del fondotinta dei prodotti ni per i
pori per fare la pelle un po più
levigata un po più photoshoppata che
dicono che la photoshop in realtà non lo
fanno per e poi passiamo altri rossetti
così non sono di marca sono di bobby
brown che un altro brand che mi piace
molto per quanto riguarda il make up
questi qui sono dei ceroni che avevo
comprato quando mi coprivo il tatuaggio
e adesso lo sto togliendo come sapete
quindi non l'uso più di tanto ma sono
perfetti per coprire quei brufoli che
proprio non riesce a coprire quel
coretto al 12 di harley sopra il corre
il questo gli toglie sempre
passiamo a questo mi chiedete dove
compro questi contenitori da cinesi
ma è difficile trovarli cesi ci sono
ovunque grazie per salvarci sempre la
vita io mi rivolgo sempre a loro e
questi fantastici nei contenitori
portatrucchi mi trovo sempre lì e ogni
volta che insomma mi arrivano dei
prodotti nuovi completi con frank e di
nuovi contenitori perché sono dove li
metto cioè quanto scaffali sono pieni
inizialmente rientra doccia risalgono
proprio non può neanche entrare in bagno
perché ci sono questi cassettini dove o
degli uni degli altri ombretti toldi
quali sono le palette qua ci sono gli
ombretti diciamo singoli e ci sono anche
quei fantastici ombretti tipo rosini e
azzurrini chiosato nel video delle medie
del riciclo ricordato tutti ecco qui
tengo per vecchi dove tramite poi qua ci
sono i mascara da ghiaccio poi ci sono i
mascara da ghiaccio o parti al tender
questo di clinique black ops mio tanti
ma scarpa ghiaccio ovviamente un viaggio
per niente quindi stanno di questo
prende la zona a zona che non si apre
mai
qui ci sono dei correttori di quando ero
una persona con un colorito un po più
decente quindi può più scuri adesso non
li posso usare ma se posso usare per
fare il contouring perché sono troppo
scuri e qui oa le matite per le
sopracciglia in versione fa sempre da
viaggio che sono ancora da aprire
perché come ho detto non ne ho ancora
avuto bisogno
qui ci sono i beauty blender c'è questo
che quello che uso più spesso però
questi che sono praticamente risalenti a
decenni fa e quindi ritengo lì per
bellezza e questi qui che mi sono
arrivati da poco sono xtra carini si
infilano dentro le dita
però ti vuoi se non li ho ancora aperti
il capire anche voi prendere prodotti
nuovi avere prodotti nuovi ma non
aprirli perché è bello comunque così
lasciarli lì e
ammirarli e sapere che ci sono
potrebbero servire però per adesso
stanno qui c'è una sezione mascara a
grande richiesta farò anche un video sui
miei mascara per adesso ve li faccia
solo vedere qua ci sono due prodotti che
mi sono arrivati da make up for ever un
illuminante sposando molto e questo è un
fondotinta che mi chiedo non avere un
presente chi fossi perché non mi puoi
dare questo come fondotinta c'è un po
ring people panor però grazie make up
for ever e niente qua abbiamo finito
questi sì l'ho già tornato 26 ago anche
amianti ai piani alti c'è in più ti non
c'è più il make up ma non aspetta
dimenticato questo la sezione più
importante i pennelli che è la o
spessissimo con questo prodotto mi sono
anche limitatevi farvi vedere cioè
stiamo tornando ai piani bassi
questo prodotto che vuol dire che ha
dimenticato di far vedere è appunto un
lava pennelli voi vi chiederete marina
ma che cosa è questo oggetto strano è un
lama pennelli ragazze lo so come se
volete vedere funziona e niente mette
questo prodottino che vendono insomma
apposta per questo aggeggio si prende e
questo e si sceglie 2a del somma
pennello che dobbiamo
che dobbiamo lavare la dimensione di
questo chiamiamolo cappuccio in silicone
che va a infilarsi qua poi a far salire
e poi cosa succede questo adesso vi
spruzzo tutto vale vedete è una figata
perché il pennello gira si lava
dopo di ciò se lo alzate si asciuga
quindi in questo momento il pennello si
sta asciugando e quindi quando spegnete
il tutto non ci crederete mai mai
pennello è pulito e asciutto cioè questa
è l'intenzione del secolo un applauso
chi ha alimentato style crew e questi
sono i pennelli ci sono quelli penali in
cui vado molto fiera tipo questo per il
fondotinta questo per fissante questo
per il placet tutti i pennelli di
qualità per quanto riguarda i pennelli
degli occhi farci abbastanza pietà
perché sono tremendi tipo questo mi è
tornato questo che tutto duro perché non
ho trovato
non ho ben nove questo tipo nero perché
era il contrario mini non si vedeva che
era sporco e insomma i pennelli per gli
occhi diciamo che dovrei darmi una
sveglia e comprarli nuovi
saliamo definitivamente in alto qua c'è
una zona beauty e qua c'è tutta la
sezione deodorante in cinque o sei
perché a seconda di come mi sveglio
metodi odoranti diverso questo è quello
per pelli delicate e qua c'è la crema di
clinique che uso spesso come base
qua c'è un'altra prima cosa come base e
questa è la zona kills
con questi prodotti molto idratanti e
per pelli sensibili questa la maschera
non ho mai aperto forse perché è al
pomodoro e diciamo che è un po ovunque
tanto che altro non so se profumerà
questa è la mia crema corpo insieme a
questa sempre per pelli delicate perché
ho la pelle più delicata di un bambino
appena nato borotalco shampoo a secco sì
ero da mettere a punto prima del trucco
e questa maschera di kills la black mask
che ho usato una volta su salvo perché
dovevo testarlo su qualche cavia e
infatti lo testate su di lui poi non ho
mai più usata è questa invece tutta la
linea benefit e appunto del per il viso
con crema occhi contorno occhi allora
torniamo ai piani alti questi sono i
piani alti per quanto riguarda la cura
dei capelli e o prodotti soprattutto di
raskin di sue mura e di kérastase questa
la zona styling quindi voglio un cliente
crema insomma termica per da mettere
prima di casa la piastra qui anche un
prodotto termico qui è la mia ricci
quella linea volume sempre ricci e qui è
la linea nutriente e diciamo che vi ho
fatto vedere praticamente tutti i miei
trucchi e tutti i miei prodotti qualcosa
magari mancherà tipo le maschere che ho
in quell altra sezione
però ragazzi
come tutte le donne sono piena quindi
potrei tirarne fuori anche dal soffitto
ma quanto sono glamour i miei cotton
fioc piano lo specchietto sono
reclinabili e hanno la punta per andare
al punto a levare le bella quello grazie
all'aiuto da casa e abbiamo subito la
linea nostra vita giornalista si barbara
e marina appena finito di girare un suo
nuovo video ci teniamo tantissimo a far
sapere agli spettatori di pomeriggio
cinque che possono gentilmente
iscriversi al suo canale se non hanno
ancora fatto e attivare le notifiche
cliccando sulla campanella accanto al
tasso d'iscrizione e soprattutto a di
seguirla su tutti gli altri social
infatti marina non ha solo youtube
anche facebook anche instagram era anche
music ha ri correte a seguirla e top
adoro atti la linea barbara
[Musica]